jamar chase
here he is talking about the possibility
of playing with his
former college quarterback joe burrow in
cincinnati where bower is now the
starting quarterback
i have talked to the bengals um i don't
know how many times i've talked to them
though
um
but me and joe you know i i wouldn't
mind going back with joe um
you know if we go back together we're
trying to get back on chemistry and have
some more fun i think i would have an
advantage if i was to play with him only
because we played a couple years
but
we'll still have to get that groove back
ahead you know feel for it again it's
not just going to be there when we throw
again so we have to build that chemistry
back up and work hard again
remember this year under the rules of
the second season of the pandemic teams
can talk to as many prospects as they
want they have limits on the number of
times they can speak to them but every
team could talk to jamar chase if it
wants to so the fact that the bengals
have spoken to him i would suspect most
teams have spoken to him just to do
their due diligence and because they can
shireen but it's clearly an area of need
for the bengals aj green leaves you of
your agency john ross a top 10 pick back
in 2017 leaves via free agency they've
got a need there and i'm sure burrow
wouldn't be all that upset about one of
his former college teammates joining him
in cincinnati
well i did notice mike on that and
correct me if i'm wrong did you see the
shirt he was wearing it said jets on it
right did i miss something there was he
trying to tell us something with the
jets shirt that he was wearing
you know usually i noticed those details
i don't think that's new york jets
though that could be winnipeg jets are
they still a thing that doesn't that's
not the j matt casey's the jets fan that
doesn't look like an official jets thing
but uh i don't know maybe he's shooting
his shot to be second overall zach
wilson you don't need a franchise
quarterback even though you haven't had
one in 50 years in new york you need
another keyshawn johnson maybe that's
what he's angling for but uh good good
eye good eye i usually pride myself on
those meaningless details from press
conferences i'm still mesmerized by the
fact that bruce arian's face was as red
as his shirt in what we saw to start the
show
keeping in postseason form from 2020 but
uh yeah look
quarterback number one quarterback
number two quarterback number three
there's a thought that it's gonna be a
quarterback at number four i'd say the
falcons more likely to take a
quarterback than a receiver could be
bengals clear shot at chase if that's
who they want at number five leaving
devonta smith on the board for the
dolphins at number six if that's how it
all shakes out so
that 438 solidifies chase as maybe the
top receiver because he's not 170 pounds
i got no problem with devonta smith
being 170. but if i got a guy who's
explosive a dynamic and fast can catch
and he's not 170 that that's
you know i'm not going to fault a guy
for being more than 170 i'm not going to
fault smith for being 170. i'm
definitely not going to fault a guy for
being more than 170 shireen
yeah and mike you know there were some
impressive numbers that he had today at
the pro day to me that were bigger than
the 438 right i mean he had a 41 inch
vertical hit 11 foot broad jump those
are outstanding numbers for him and he
measured over six feet which i think was
important there was a thought that maybe
he was under six feet tall he wasn't he
measured at six feet over six feet so i
think that was all positive for him i
would have loved to have seen him play
last year with the quarterback other
than joe burrow as much as they
struggled on offense just to see what he
could have done to play without justin
jefferson to see if he could have had
sort of that same year that he had the
year before i realized joe burrow was
better than any quarterback that lsu
threw out there last year but he had
outstanding numbers in 2019 he was the
best receiver in football he was better
than justin jefferson who was on the
same seat on the same team and we saw
what justin jefferson did when he got to
the nfl so everyone loves this guy they
think he's going to be a star i think
it's a great receiver class
i'm not sure kind of like last year mike
we saw six receivers go in the first
round and i don't know that you can go
wrong there's going to be one or two who
are going to be better than the others i
mean we saw it this year justin
jefferson was a 22nd overall pick and he
was the best of that group last year cd
lamb had a really good year the first
two guys drafted henry ruggs and jerry
judy didn't have quite so good a year so
i love this guy i know nfl scouts love
this guy i'm not going to be surprised
if he's the first non-quarterback off
the board mike and wherever he goes i
think he's going to be a standout player
and you mentioned the bengals he would
fit right in with tyler boyd and t
higgins next year and they would have a
good group of receivers for joe burrow
extra pressure higher expectations to be
that first receiver off the board and
i've argued in the past it's actually
better for a receiver to go lower than
he thought he should have gone it lights
a little bit of a fire it makes him more
determined when you're that first guy
you've got you've got no real reason
maybe maybe that's what the jets shirt
is about maybe he's trying to convince
himself he should be number two so if he
is number five he can still be pissed
off about something even though he's the
first receiver off the board now that
438 40 if that number sounds familiar
that was 15 years ago vernon davis out
of maryland ran a 438 but he's a tight
end today florida the top tight end on
the board kyle pitts 4-4-4 not as fast
as davis but pretty darn fast and the
83-inch wingspan the longest of any
receiver or tight end in this year's
draft shireen there's a thought that
this is a guy who's going to go very
high tight ends typically typically now
we know a couple of years ago
tj hawkinson went went top 10 for the
lions but typically you see them go
later than receivers the best receivers
go before the best tight ends for the
most part but this is a guy who who
could be right in the thick of things
with the first receivers off the board
absolutely mike and he's going to be a
weapon for somebody you know he finished
10th in the heisman race for good reason
he did have a little bit of a few
injuries last year some lingering stuff
i know he had a concussion at one point
and he had some lingering injury course
in college you never know what they have
but teams are going to check that out
and be thoroughly convinced that that
he's a hundred percent now but put up
great numbers last year uh with kyle
trask as his quarterback and i just
think somebody's going to get an
outstanding tight end i know greg olson
i saw he tweeted today and and called
him a really special talent and greg
olson would know special talents at that
position matt rule by the way was the
first coach to offer kyle pitts a
scholarship
coming out of high school so i think
there's interest there but
he's probably going to be gone if the
panthers wanted mike to replace uh greg
olson what greg olson did i realized he
didn't play there last year but what he
did in his history in carolina they're
gonna have to trade up to get him
kyle pitts addressed the question of
whether or not the team that currently
holds the fourth pick in the draft and a
team that knows a thing or two about
having a great tight end guy named tony
gonzalez
has he heard from the falcons here's
pitts on that subject
i did talk to myself a couple times and
i talked to my head today and they're
saying they have interest in me and uh
after after today we'll get back on
another zone and try you know they'll
try and learn more about myself so
i feel like they're pretty interested in
you know it would be a dream come true
to be even be top five or the first
uh non-quarterback to come on the board
yeah that uh that would be something if
the falcons would take him at number
four
the question the falcons would have to
ask themselves could they
trade that spot to a quarterback needy
team like the carolina panthers doing
business in the division drop down to
eight and still get pits that's part of
the risk that you take
because maybe maybe the next pick off
the board is pits if you do slide down a
few spots but uh the falcons that's an
area of need for them they got so many
areas of need that's why the idea of
them taking a guy like trey lance and
sims has heard the talk about lance
possibly being the falcons choice when
you've got a bunch of needs the idea
that you're taking the quarterback
that's going to sit behind matt ryan for
a year maybe two probably one who knows
but
you'd think that there are other areas
that you need to address if you want to
be competitive this year maybe they
maybe they don't want to be as
competitive they can as they can be and
they're thinking more about building for
the future regardless they're sitting
there at four and as pitts said shireen
they're interested uh in him
yeah it's going to be so interesting
mike to see where the quarterbacks stop
and and i'm going to be surprised if a
quarterback doesn't go at four whether
it's the falcons or another team you
know the falcons could certainly trade
down if there's a team interested like
you said the panthers possibly moving up
to get a quarterback there but i just
you know those quarterbacks always go
higher than you think they're going to
go
and i i just think we're going to have a
run on quarterbacks early and it's going
to be an interesting conversation to see
where the next guy falls is it kyle
pitts uh is it jamar chase is it devante
smith who is it that next guy and i
think everyone's pretty much agreed from
what i've heard from scouts that chase
is the better prospect than smith right
now just based on his size so i'm going
to expect that it's going to be jamar
chase the next guy off the board after
the quarterbacks but the question
becomes where do the quarterbacks stop
is it three is it four is it even later
than that do teams get scared like the
49ers did and say hey if we want a
quarterback we're going to have to move
up to get one
it would be amazing if the run on
quarterbacks goes one two three four
five and that's entirely possible with
the bengals having to trade out because
surely they would not be taking a
quarterback for the second straight year
with a top 10 pick not after the way joe
burrow performed last year a team in the
first round that i think it's safe to
say will not be taking a tight end
although who knows with what they did in
free agency john ooh smith right out of
the gates hunter henry the next day
patriots getting back to having multiple
competent tight ends
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports